a good friend of mine in my building had
a really really interesting way of
managing talent to get and drive higher
performance and output
this will be a short video um but i
wanted to share with you so if you're
new to the channel my name is alex from
rosie owen acquisition.com we do about
85 million a year and i have nothing to
sell you um and so the reason i wanted
to make this video is because at the end
of the day every entrepreneur has the
same problem which is they need better
people and they need to get more out of
the people that they have and a lot of
that comes from culture and training but
every once in a while you stumble upon a
process that has teeth and so i haven't
implemented this yet um it's not normal
for me to make a video about something
like this but we will be implementing uh
something like this in our holding
company and so i think it's super cool
because it it is reinforced through
multiple
different psychological uh levers
and it's got really cool stuff to it so
let's dive in one of the things that he
shared with me that he did is that he
has a level of variable compensation
that's not new it means that there's
some level of performance check marks
etc that they have to hit in order to
get paid makes sense now the way that
most companies do this and i'll tell you
that what we've done up to this point
for us is that in positions where that
are not direct like sales for example
it's very easy to have a commission
structure etcetera but for let's say
leadership and executive positions uh
and so this is important if you're
trying to build your you know your solo
partnership into an actual company that
has values you need to have people who
are all aligned and driving hard like
owners towards the same goal and
honestly it's much more enjoyable that
way and so the way that we have split
our things up to this point is that we
do something called mbos which is
management by objectives which are for
the company and then uh also for the
individual so we usually split them 50
50. so let's say we've got a leader who
let's say like a director of marketing
it's gonna they're not going to like get
a sale but we know that they're in
charge of all of the you know rain
making for that particular business line
they might get let's say let's just use
round numbers let's say they're making
their targeted earnings is two hundred
thousand dollars we're gonna give them a
hundred thousand dollar base and we're
gonna give them a hundred thousand
dollars of variable compensation right
now of that variable compensation that
half we split that again in half half of
that which would be 25 of their total
comp is gonna be of whether the company
grows overall so if we hit x y and z uh
metrics they'll get
you know of growth or new sales or
profitability then they're going to get
those things right and the other half is
going to be on whether they did
something personally that they have
control over so it might be adding a new
channel or a new platform or creating
some sort of process that we want to
automate um or bringing in a new xyz
manager right those would be things that
they have complete control over that we
can checkbox even if the business
doesn't do well or doesn't hit the goals
of growth or just you know marginally
grows they can still get half of their
variable comp so if you've got 100 grand
they got that guaranteed and they've got
50 that as long as they do their all
their stuff they've got and then they
get to participate in the upside of the
business if the business overall grows
right and so that is how we've done it
up to this point it's worked well right
but what he presented was a different
way that i really really really liked
and a key part of this is that the
management by objectives and the things
that we set we set for our team
okay so they don't have a choice in it
they just accept it or you know they
might try to negotiate a couple terms
but that that's more or less how the
compensation structure works right with
the way that he sets it up is that every
position has a level of variable
compensation
that level you can determine you know
you can say you want it to be 10 or you
can be 20 or it could be 50 you know it
depends on the role but maybe let's say
a frontline customer service rule let's
say we wanted to make a you know let's
say 15 of their compensation variable so
if they're targeting let's say 50 000 a
year then that would mean 7 500
would be potential to be variable so
that would be like whatever 600 bucks a
month ish right of their compensation is
kind of in the air hung in the balance
and so here's the cool thing what he
does
is that he says this is the variable
comp
and you get
to set the goal every month
so it's a 30-day rolling goal
and every month
they get to set the goal
of what they're going to do they have to
you know show it publicly so you get
some social pressure in there right you
also get autonomy because they're the
ones who are picking it
and so here's what's cool if everybody
on the team has to say what their
personal goal is right
and they get to set it and if they hit
their personal goal as long as it's
aligned with the company goal overall
like it's going to contribute to that
goal then they can make it right they
have to obviously prove that it in some
way furthers the overall uh division or
department's goal but as long as it's
aligned in that the extent to it and the
amount that they have to hit has got to
be quantifiable right
if they set that goal they can set it as
bigger as little as they want what
happens
is that the social pressure
of wanting to set good goals
automatically self corrects you might
think well what if they just say they
get you know a half a percent you know
improvement or something like that and
then they hit it cool but the thing is
is that people on the team
are going to be like dude come on that's
the goal
and then all of a sudden they raise it
but they raised it
no one else
and so they have complete autonomy and
ownership over that goal now for you as
an owner what you can do obviously is
let's say that your targeted earnings
for the person's fifty thousand a year
that's fine you just take fifteen
percent and make it variable so like
they have the potential to earn the
whole thing or they have to earn
somewhat less
like don't worry about the variable
column the the piece is that we have
intermittent reinforcement which is
another way of saying variable reward
for an employee they have complete
autonomy and they have social pressure
and they have some level of competition
and this is really useful in roles that
don't necessarily a directly you know
tied to the bottom line like sales does
and are more difficult
to quantify right and so
this gives those roles the opportunity
to feel like they're contributing to the
overall growth of the company and have
something in the balance
that
matters
so i wanted to share this with you
because i thought it was really really
cool we're going to be implementing
stuff like this in some of our portfolio
companies but i thought it was just
incredibly sexy and um i didn't want to
i didn't want to keep it from you
because i think it's really really cool
because there's just so much psychology
behind
doing things this way um and
it just allows everyone to participate
and grow as
employees within the company and as a as
a tangential tertiary benefit of this
your churn will go down because people
will feel like they're making progress
pretty cool right if they'll feel like
they're making progress and that they
are growing and that they are
challenging themselves and that at the
end of the day is what you want every
workplace uh to fulfill for your
employees now whether they feel
fulfilled you have no control over but
if you can create an environment that
increases the likelihood that they feel
that way given a normal human construct
um
i think that you're going to build a
better business so lots of love keep
being awesome mozy nation love you all
and i'll see you guys next video bye